[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce sera une nouvelle date dans les
annales de saint nazaire capitale des
constructions navales que celle du
premier départ du paquebot france dont
on pourra dire demain qu'il est le plus
beau paquebot du monde tirait par-ci
remorqueur le g1 a pris le large pour
ses essais en mer qui le mèneront au
havre son futur port d'attache pour ce
premier voyage le paquebot emporté 700
hommes d'équipage et 700 ingénieurs et
ouvriers qui achèveront pendant cette
croisière les travaux d'aménagement
tout sera prêt pour la première
traversée le havre new york
ou sahara le gaz continuent de brûler au
puits de gassies twin une flamme de 200
m 15 millions de mètres cubes qui
s'évanouissent chaque jour les 860
mètres de la tige du forage éjecté gît
sur le sable fondu tordu
l'intense chaleur dégagée créer un puits
sans appel d'air l'air chaud aspirer
semble couler et chose est un homme dans
ce pays de la sécheresse la torche de
gassi touil fabrique des nuages
l'homme restera t-il impuissant à
réduire cet incendie qui de l'avis des
experts pourrait durer cent ans
de même que le 11 novembre il avait été
salué les morts de la guerre le général
de gaulle est allé rendre visite à
d'autres victimes les grands blessés
dans cette institution nationale des
invalides on ne le sait pas assez vives
ou reçoivent les soins nécessaires des
mutilés des blessés d'hier et
d'avant-hier
[Musique]
l'effort que vous accomplissez pour
surmonter votre douleur est un exemple
auxquels je rends hommage leur a dit le
chef de l'état c'est ainsi que vous
continuez à servir je vous remercie au
nom de la france
à la garderie sur larmes le chef de
l'état français avait rendez vous avec
l'abbé fulbert youlou président de la
république du congo 8e chefs d'état de
l'afrique d'expression française à être
reçu à paris
il ya tant de liens qui unissent nos
deux pays disait en l'accueillant le
général de gaulle ces paroles devaient
trouver leurs prolongements à l'elysée
un peu plus tard où les deux hommes se
retrouvaient en tête à tête pour un
premier entretien
cette visite est à la fois un espoir et
une conclusion brazzaville on s'en
souvient est à l'origine du grand
mouvement français qui devaient opérer
l'évolution des pays d'afrique noire
[Musique]
la reine elizabeth et le duc d'edimbourg
ont déchaîné les tam-tams sur
l'aérodrome d'accra capitale du ghana où
ils étaient les autres du président
truman il faut dire que le ghana n'avait
rien négligé pour faire un succès de la
visite royale à commencer par la parade
militaire qui comportait un trooping the
colour d'importation très réussi
le folklore autochtone a bien entendu
été lui aussi mis à contribution au
cours de ce voyage qui avait failli être
annulée au dernier moment pour des
motifs de sécurité et qui sait en dépit
des pronostics révélé triomphal
l'heure h à sonné pour les concours dont
philippe herria s'est fait le porte
parole pour 261 a été attribué à
monsieur jean cau pour son roman la
pitié de dieu au troisième tour en même
temps c'est la tradition était attribué
le prix renaudot et les dix n'ont eu que
quelques pas à faire pour féliciter avec
les journalistes l'heureux lauréat du
renaudot roger bordier
le mérite unis a la chance c'est le prix
de miss chine hier secondes de miss
monde aujourd'hui promu à ce titre du
fait du mariage de l'élu au lendemain de
son élection
c'est à paris à l'ambassade de chine que
la nouvelle miss monde a fêté sa
promotion entre miss madagascar miss
hollande et miss france
[Musique]
encore un prix mais d'un autre genre au
cours d'une vente de tableaux anciens
qu'on peut nommer la vente du siècle à
new york le record des prix a été
atteint par un rembrandt aristote
contemplant le buste d'homère qui a
atteint le prix fabuleux 2,1 milliards
150 millions d'anciens francs
on n'avait pas prévu cela il l'avait pas
pour 500 fleurs
[Musique]
élima maillot foncé culotte blanche
n'ont pas amené le soleil du midi sous
leurs crampons stade bollaert à lens le
soleil était plutôt du côté des joueurs
lensois qui jongle en ce moment avec nos
adversaires au bout d'une demi-heure de
ce petit jeu big ans qui le demi gauche
de lens marque le premier but de son
équipe
et les offensives de lens continue
wisnieski numéro 9 qui jouera peut-être
dans la prochaine équipe de france
coordonne parfaitement les mouvements de
ses attaquants et lens ne va pas tarder
à marquer son second but
voilà qui dément rien ne va plus à nice
lens en effet poursuit ses offensives
toujours avec le même père sans les
nîmois ne savent plus où se placer pour
empêcher leurs adversaires de tirer au
but à 0 pour la est dans le coin des
supporteurs les nîmois ne font pas le
poids a endurées par les apparences du
moins
[Applaudissements]
dans les dernières minutes les nîmois à
leur tour marqué un but ce qui n'empêche
pas cependant l'équipe d'être battu par
3 à
les espoirs parisiens alors du
rock'n'roll ça c'est du scoop
vague n'a rien inventé ce qu'elle
appelle aujourd'hui rock du temps de
grand papa sa porte et déjà un nom on
appelait ça la danse de 5
pas de la fête
remarquez que quelles que soient les
circonstances si on perd le nord en
revanche verges a mérité
la valse des bâtons plan pourrait bien
définitif prendre le pas sur la
bilan de ces petits festivals 2 millions
de dégâts quelques postes des yeux au
beurre noir et un cimetière de chaises
cassées bref du grand art
pourquoi donc vous en plaindre monsieur
van himst alors vous y est peut-être
pour quelque chose
[Musique]